[Music]
Alysha bow dishes on her beauty must
haves and on her hopes for season 3 of
13 reasons why justice will be served
eats he caught up with the actress on
the pink carpet
during vidicon 2018 in Los Angeles what
karma do you think Bryce deserves after
what happened in season two having him
in season three oh I mean I just hope
that justice will be served and that's
all you can oh but I hope he gets the
justice he deserves agreed it doesn't
stop how would you say your makeup style
differs from Jessica
oh well Jessica doesn't wear any no yeah
she's 16 so I would say I'm more I'm
more daring I guess and I like to wear
like a thick weighing in the eyeliner
when I go out and read lipstick and you
know I like to have fun what are 13 and
beauty products that you can't live
without I don't know if I can name 13
but I will say I love a soft like facial
wash face wash okay um a soft moist
riser and I really love I used the mad
face and body foundation lightweight
yeah and then I always use like a Mac
deep red lipstick and then I use the
glossy a
the glossier their blood the cream blush
in like a very crushed berry color but
that's like my everyday look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]